l'eczéma rebond soir vous avez publié
cet hiver chez denoël un roman intitulé
petit frère qui raconte l'assassinât
d'un jeune dj juifs par son ami
d'enfance musulmans et qui plonge au
coeur des conflits communautaires de la
société française d'aujourd'hui voilà
alors le narrateur est un ex militant de
sos racisme et il se rend compte
finalement à l'occasion de cette enquête
qui lui est demandée par un ami du
gouvernement des illusions et des
mensonges de sa génération c'est un
roman qui a beaucoup choqué les gens
n'ont pour deux raisons d'une part parce
que j'ai voulu raconter au delà du crime
en fait la vie dans un immeuble d'un
quartier populaire d'aujourd'hui même
pas en banlieue à paris dans le 19ème et
donc que je raconte tout la dégradation
la communautarisation là des gens qui au
départ dans une ambiance très
sympathique etc et qui finalement
finissent par se haïr les uns les autres
et ça c'était terrible et en même temps
je montre mon art acteurs effectivement
c'est plus qu'un militants de
l'antiracisme c'est via une grosse crise
mme oui voilà c'est un gauchiste ses
intimes qui était une vedette de la télé
et au départ il est plein de certitudes
plein de conviction tous ses combats
passés et quand ils arrivent là il
est sidéré par justement l'ambiance qui
y règne ambiance délétère et où il se
dit mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait alors il
ya une phrase en exergue d'une phrase
d'alain finkielkraut
l'antiracisme et le communisme du 21e
siècle il faut bien comprendre que
l'anti racisme a été créée forget c'est
un mouvement des années 80 vous souvenez
par d'anciens trotskistes d'anciens
communistes et ils ont troqué exactement
les idéaux communistes pour des idéaux
anti raciste simplement on a remplacé la
classe ouvrière par la race et on a les
mêmes méthodes c'est à dire que si vous
savez vous souvenez jean paul sartre
disait tout anticommuniste un chien est
l'atout celui qui n'est pas anti raciste
est un fasciste et nazie et c'est donc
c'est la même eau le même ostracisme
moralisateur sur des pans entiers
raciste qu'est ce qu'on a mais racistes
comme l'a justement c'est ce qu'ont
voulu nous faire croire les antiracistes
excuse moi mais quand j'étais au lycée
au moment c'est apparu on mettait tout
ça me touche pas à mon pote c'était
quelque chose de fort c'était pas qu'on
n'était pas de communistes et non mais
j'étais à manipuler c'est pareil non
gmail s'est passé quelque chose mais moi
ça a changé mon regard en franche et
bayal oui mais sur les gens non mais
c'est pas parce que c'est pas parce que
c'est un idéal que c'est forcément bien
mais on va quand même débit
et
la pression parce que je veux dire c'est
que la khl à la petite main jaune elle a
été inventée à l'elysée par le connais
bien on file on vient deuxièmement
deuxièmement deuxièmement elle est jaune
exactement comme l'étoile jaune on voit
bien le on voit bien là il a serré
rouget de lisle chose c'est pas parce
que l'objectif est bien c'est pas parce
que l'on veut c'est le meilleur de
l'homme et comment ce mouvement fait
changer les mentalités en france oui moi
je trouve en mal alors soit sa a été
créée par des bureaux et c'était
peut-être penser et donc il y avait
peut-être pas de mouvements spontanés
d'un produit de la création de ce fruit
mais je me souviens que c'était une
nouvelle manière de voir les tout d'un
coup on mettait le doigt sur quelque
chose que je pouvais vivre que ramzi
pouvait vivre que l'autre bout n'y
aucune arrivée
que personne n'avait rassemblé sous un
petit drapeau avec une main jaune et
tout d'un coup il y avait quand même
chez nous petit peuple on y aller
spontanément on était soit manipulée
mais il y avait un vrai mouvement de
coeur je pense et je pense que le
mais le coeur d'être a forcément raison
écoutez je préfère vivre avec le choeur
personnellement mais je préfère vivre
avec la tête est ce que voulait dire
c'est qu'on fait avec ça qui fait l'ange
fait la bête dit pantalon connaît et
elle connaît aussi nascar on cite trop
de gens ont peut pas parler normalement
sans faire d'une lime dropping à touba
suffisait pas d'avoir lu des livres
récuse moi d'avoir à vue des livres vous
sous-entendez quoi avec ce à dire que
vous me reprochez de citer les auteurs
très bien je préfère citer des auteurs
comme les approprier sans les citer et
ensuite ça va de la vanité c'est
simplement que j'estime
du respect pour ses
phrases
excusez moi moi d'avoir lu des livres
qu'est-ce que ça sous-entend sassoon
autant pas que moi je n'ai rien lu ah
non ça sous-entend régula d'accord merci
je sais rien
dit est ce que j' mende avoir eu vous
sous-entendez que moi je n'ai pas lu
vous le saurez en temps réel du suicide
était bon qu'il voyait derrière au petit
rire hypocrite se cache pas
j'ai beaucoup lu et c'est pas qu'on
grandit en cité et que j'ai le teint
basané que je n'ai pas lu j'ai moi aussi
essayé dans la tête mon cher ami
jean beaulieu mais moi ce que je partage
avec un vent très léger conditions
vous mais c'est comme ça ça me rend fou
encore parce que encore aujourd'hui
avant l ennemi qu avant d'être connu
j'étais vraiment étoiles à this tout ça
maintenant je suis plus trop en arabe
qu'est ce que c'est vrai mais
aujourd'hui encore malgré tout est
résumé dans les émissions comme ça moi
monsieur je dois mieux encore des gens
qui jouent à dix jeux j'ai lu plus que
toi mon gars rien vu mais je dois moi
j'ai encore mes chéries chéris
rétabli on s'entendait il vraiment les
gens jusque là elle est là calais et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus